oh
take a breath and relax
release any tensions in your body
and just have the thinking mind take a
break
and you'll notice a really simple shift
as you take these inhalations
you relax away the tensions
you'll notice
prior the mind was jumping
between thoughts like they're chained
together
from one to the next when you simply
turn the attention on the breath and
turn the attention
on attention itself becoming aware
of awareness itself and aware of your
breath
itself aware of relaxation
itself
of where aware of just being alive
itself
you'll notice that the thinking mind
slows down
and just tune in right now to the
intention
of what we're doing with this show
specifically this
show has evolved
so much over the last couple of years
continuously following the biggest
questions
and wanting to know the nature of
reality
and this seems to be the most fast way
the quickest way to know
what your true nature is is to ask the
biggest questions
what is the nature of my reality what is
the nature
of consciousness
is this a manifestation of infinity
how do we maximize our potential
individually collectively
and when you ask these biggest questions
inevitably you're going to be led to
more signal
this is what you could say is the direct
path to know the nature of reality
and especially
where i'm coming from now
versus where i was coming from earlier
now
more and more of my heart is with you
more and more of my intention is to
support you
in you asking the big questions in you
finding the signals and the answers
in you being able to rejoice
in the peace
and the love that is our true nature
and how that maximizes your individual
prosperity
as well as the collective prosperity
there is only one
intelligence at play and this is
what happens when you follow these
biggest questions
to the signal to the truth
and so as we take this breath and we
relax
all of our conceptual thinking all of
our describing
every time we do that we break the chain
of
thinking and we break
our networks and webs
of conditioning were conditioned
perpetually
to jump from thought to thought
nonstop
and these greatest planetary mystic
traditions and again mysticism simply
means becoming one
with god yoga union means becoming one
with god
with absolute with the highest
we already all are that
but this chain of thinking
creates these clouds of obscuration
that prevent us from seeing the true
nature
and so whenever you take these
inhalations
you become aware of awareness you relax
any tensions in your body and you stop
the conceptual mind from describing and
thinking
so the most common example is you're no
longer thinking about
the items that you have on the calendar
for tomorrow
you're no longer thinking about the
people that you have to reply to
you're no longer thinking about the
action items that you have going on
about food about sleep about your
relationships
and those are normally where our
thoughts jump around incessantly
and so as you undergo this process of
just inhaling and relaxing
that thinking mind you'll notice that
those
clouds thoughts slowly
become less and less strong
in drawing you out to them and you
become more and more aware
of what happens when you're not jumping
from thought to thought
and this is what we mean
through this video this very simple
explanation of the core of spirituality
the core
of mysticism the core of yoga
we're simply asking you to
see as god sees
we're simply asking you to
decondition yourself from those
webs of thoughts
that are dragging you around all day
non-stop
that are making you feel like you have
lack
i'm not enough i'm not worthy
i'm not loved i'm not seen
so now i as a person that's not
loved not worthy not seen have to focus
non-stop on this web of thinking
for me to be able to extract validation
from other people and then i'll be happy
and then i'll be peaceful
so we're asking you to recognize
that that entire process is of
the person and we're asking you
to lovingly radically
accept that beautiful
lower frequency process
it was there to serve us in this
creation
but we are radically lovingly accepting
it
and then we are shifting
from that lower frequency
of all of the separate person
conditioning
and we're purifying to god
to seeing the way god sees to this very
primordial oneness
the simple shift from
the separate person
and its webs of conditioning and
thinking
feeling i am unworthy i am not
loved i am not seen and now i need to
extract
all of this validation
whereas when you purify by breaking that
chain of thinking
and just relaxing the tensions
and recognizing the very nature
of the fact that
you already are
worthy god already
is 100 worthy
every single one of us is 100 worthy
it's like all of our cups are already
100 full
and then the person undergoes the
illusion
of feeling that their cup is not 100
full and then going out trying to seek
validation and being seen and getting
acknowledged as being worthy from family
and friends and co-workers via clout
via fame via money
via material success
the shift as we purify
all of that person conditioning
to seeing as god sees rather than seeing
as the person sees which is a lower
frequency
we shift up to this higher frequency of
seeing
as god sees the very primordial oneness
of it all
we see that our cup was 100
full the whole time we were worthy
we were 100 percent loved the whole time
and that's when we relax
we see as god sees we see that the
entire creation
is one intelligence
it's simply one infinite creator
endlessly expressing itself in this
universe this creation is but
one manifestation it's but one
exploration
it's but one of infinite possibilities
for us to play for us to explore for us
to get to know
ourselves
and so then you see that primordial
oneness when you relax
that thinking mind that's constantly
jumping around
trying to extract worthiness
and slowly you decondition yourself
from that
and what happens when you decondition
yourself from that
is you relax more and more
into the already always
100 worthy god state
and you see everything as that
primordial oneness
the shift this purification that we're
talking about
is more and more over time
coming from seeing as god sees
instead of coming from the lower
frequency of seeing as the separate
conditioned
person that's under the illusion that
their cup
is only partly full and that they need
to get it filled up
by jumping in their conditioned web of
thought and extracting
validation and peace and happiness
from people from family friends
co-workers society fame wealth
money clout material possessions
and so forth
and so this is simple spirituality
this is what our channel is
really bringing from our hearts
to yours
the most simple distillations
of what the nature of reality is
the most simple ways for us
to recognize our true nature
maximize our own individual prosperity
as well as the collective's
prosperity all of our goals
in entrepreneurship in
science engineering politics
art finance all of our goals
in those fields especially geopolitics
are further augmented and enhanced
by our shift from this lower frequency
of i
am unworthy as a separate conditioned
person
to i see the way god sees
and everyone's shifting to seeing the
way god
sees that is what is meant by the
awakening
that is what is meant by the planetary
enlightenment
we are making that shift collectively
so we will continue the process of
creating content to help
with this purification from this lower
frequency to this higher frequency to
seeing as god sees
and much more so
thank you for tuning in infinite love
very grateful and
if the video brought you value give it a
like
subscribe if you haven't comment below
with where you're at
in this process i'll do my best to reply
we have a simulation club
as well you can join the link is in the
bio below which has great perks
and share the video of seeing as
god sees with your friends
family co-workers people online and
let's accelerate this
planetary awakening
thank you
you